Hey shuttle,
we got,
we got down Joe Diaz,
we went deep.
We just kept smoking.
It didn't do shit to me.
Well you got to break up the gate.
We've,
when I come up here Doug,
what are you talking about?
Right?
That we just don't do shit to me.
If you make me drive 40 minutes up,
you've got to get me stolen bro.
That's us.
What?
Hannah weed I've been telling you about that shit.
Yeah,
you brought that shit to the ice house to that shit.
Don't do nothing to you and you're so crazy.
It's true to go to a doctor,
the fuck dog
dog.
You got to bust ass and good weed dog enough is enough with this shit around
like Jack you.
No it's not.
Look at my fucking eyes bro.
I look high to you guys
cause I smoke on the way cause I knew you were going to give me that such plan a
fucking weed.
Yo Man,
I don't think they heard you.
Don't you tell them what your name is?
I would like to know my too is when I have three thinking nothing else.
It's amazing.
You know,
women realize that,
you know,
when they realize that when they try to become men like leg Chaz Bono and don't,
like I said today,
he can't fucking just strap a pair nugget town and go out there and sling.
I always fucking know that you're the real deal.
You know who you can and you've been sucking Dick for 20 years now.
You want to change fucking governments.
You can't do that shit.
You can change government changing government.
20 years ago I went to a club to get Quain loot and I walked in,
I never forget,
there's like a,
it was called Ramrod.
There was a gay bar in the city.
We were kids.
We were like 18 and I walked into this club and before we walked in there was a
fetish club on the side and there was a guy in a tub that had a sign on them
that said spit on me.
That was his fetish for people to spit on him.
So here's the beauty.
I'm standing there,
you know,
your joy is gone.
You're drinking.
You know you had a pea and Austin,
they see 20 guys standing on line for the fucking bathroom,
and I asked him,
I go,
listen,
why don't you just ask the guy in the Tub if we could pee on?
So I walked over to the guy,
look,
can I ask you a question?
Do you mind if we pray on you?
The guys go right ahead.
There was a point in the night I looked at him,
he had a circle of guys just bringing all those guys that don't want to wait on
line.
Like fuck it,
just piano.
When I left to go ahead and three inches of p in the fucking dog,
if the sign was all fucking and melted,
this guy wanted people to spill out and we ended up pissing on it and I pissed
down and I'm guilty of,
I don't give a fuck.
It is decided by Deka,
Latin in North Bergen,
New Jersey.
These cops got together.
There's,
I'm from a real corrupt police town and they call this bar the Meadowlands in
and there was a gogo bond only avenue and on Wednesday night it was erotic
banana night for two bucks.
They give you a frozen banana and you walk into the Strip club,
you peel the banana,
you gave it to the chick,
she shoved in a pussy,
she gave it back to you ate it at Christmas.
He was always in there.
One year I go in there and I'm sad.
The bottom,
this is old guy that had like a stage in the middle and then you sit around the
side,
but the chicks would put their foot and climb over.
That's how this is 1980 dog.
This was strictly as you could kill a bitch in a strip club.
You know what I'm saying?
In a strip club rod and $50 that was on the menu
and if 50 get to kill me,
that would be 60 I'm about 16 I calm my little pussy bow as a professional.
I didn't know about the dirty things.
I lied.
I'm saying this mother fucker took his,
she took his false teeth up and stuck them in a snatch and put them back.
Then he put them in his mouth on Christmas Eve.
I love people who think they're going to be the year with test those fucking
clowns.
Kevin Randleman was awesome.
It was primal.
I love those fucking clowns cause I was with them.
I always thought I was a little bit BB does system.
I used to drink vinegar now I used to do an eight ball on Friday,
eight ball and Sam and then they would have to test me on Monday for federal
probation or Wednesday or Friday.
I could make the pis tache Wednesday,
but there's no way I can make rock candy coming out of high was fucking vinegar.
Flavored rock can always get white distilled vinegar with a bottle of Gatorade
and I'd be cranberries,
but I try.
So then I failed actress and I came up with another idea.
I forget about drinking.
I'm going to take my own circumcised Dick and I'm going to pull the skin back
and I'm going to pull them my products in there.
I thought it out and I said to myself,
what kills piss on the floor rocks,
but I can't sneak that as the money.
I said,
what's the next best thing to kill pace?
So I figured out pool cleaners.
So I went to my buddy's house who had a pool,
you know those big things that you say,
oh no rain.
And I grabbed it.
I drive it,
that motherfucker.
And I took my little skin on my helmet and I pulled my back before I went to
probation,
my Dick and I just poured all the,
the whole fucking thing on my dick
and they'd pull the skin off and I try like a rubber band that
I walk into probation piss Mr piece.
I take that dig out and I'd pop that skin back and all that mold chain,
old bus goes in there and that thing starts breathing on his own.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
I put the cap on it.
The thing is on his desk,
he could see my fucking,
you could see like shaking.
I'm like,
I gotta get well,
great to see it.
Do you know what?
I still came back positive.
The chlorine the next day didn't hurt.
I went right to the halfway house and wash my dick off,
but the next day I went to the business by,
Dick was like one of those.
This was coming out of everywhere.
What is it,
how I store holders.
Then the last thing I figured it was Draino so I took drain on.
I bought it on my big dog home.
My and I went down there.
I had fucking pissed with the Draino and this time dog.
The thing was turning red right in front of me and about four days later I get a
call,
Mr. Diaz,
can you come down to probation?
I thought there were going to handcuff me a probation.
I get any,
there's a car,
there's a probation officer and they got to go into the check.
There was a chick that I really liked when she goes,
I don't know what you did,
but you fucking broke the machine this time I really literally broke the testing
thing they had.
They couldn't even,
they didn't know what was in my system.
Some dog.
My Dick was rare.
For a fucking month.
I get away with this shit.
The saddest moment of your life is when your dick a sore.
It was something wrong with your debt.
Realize what have I done.
And on the weekends he cuts your fucking Dick off and puts that fucking monkey
that,
that checkout we met in Vegas with the artificial turf and the fucking hole that
time,
remember rather Riviera's member revealed the security came and tapped.
As you're talking to a fucking Harvey,
don't get confused.
Nothing.
Beat that dirty oil.
He's the day from Michigan.
That's the crazy bitch.
I was fucking in the ass in Seattle and I felt something hit my deck.
So I looked at her asshole like stuck like two fingers,
like something was hitting the top of my unit.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this sharp thing?
So I took my dick,
I,
she's like,
I just put two fingers and they searched around her.
So I far like a fucking little like a,
you know when you need a Hershey's bothered aluminum foil.
I incisors like half of it and I took it out,
but it was all wrinkled up and it was like this was pointing over here and I
just took it out and look at it.
It was like curly brownish.
I put on the table by taking back in there and I'm going to send them to it is
how you tell somebody to have a little bit era.
Did you steal my change jar in the late nineties probably did steal my fucking
change jar
jar.
I call you Joey jingles for awhile.
I would never ride change a fucking cup of cheese.
Yeah,
I was just bored as
fuck is wrong with that job.
A professional.
I've never watched the twilight,
but I've seen what those two little fucking half of fruit cakes look like.
I can't believe that vampires and my day vampire is a bad motherfucker.
Bottom is college that's available.
I just went deep
shadows.
Fuck guys.
You fuck chicks?
It don't matter.
You a vampire.
You Ain't gay.
You just slinked Dick.
You fucking dogs.
You were fucking animal.
You've got to fucking go and New York.
Yeah,
you got to go stop sign.
How they do here.
Like no,
you go get the fuck somebody fucking gold.
Right.
I got to get to the weed store.
It is a great story.
I just thought it was,
cause I was thinking that standing up on the way up here and a friend Mike was
selling weed and then one time he worked at CAA and he goes,
listen,
one of the interns over to him,
he blew up.
He ended up being Whitney Houston's manager
in the tour manager and he's looking for powder.
So every day they would come over and I would sell Bobby Brown and Whitney
Houston,
you know,
they would come over like $1,100 which was per diem money.
I was taking Whitney's per diem money,
right?
Every day they come out with a little white envelope and give me the per diem
money that go up to the Martell cartel and I buy 14 grams of Blo,
take an eight ball out and cut it and then give it to Whitney Houston.
And they were fucking going crazy thing.
This went on for 30 40 days,
but I couldn't smell it.
All the blogs,
I couldn't store it.
It was just too much.
Then picking me up and nine or more than page of me on the Red Pager.
I'm coming downstairs,
getting in a car with them,
going through the Martell cards out to them,
brothers going in the house with two grams of coke or when he cut in my pocket
and I would just go in and take rock sack,
throw the cutter and mix it up and give it right back to them,
the car,
and they'd be happy as shit.
I was selling them.
I was getting him a half ounce and taking an eight ball out and throwing an
eight ball or cut it.
What does enable three and a half grams,
but this is the eighth they're doing a half ounce a day,
which is three ounces a week.
Oh my God.
It's senior to the pages going off and it's sage and I said,
fuck it.
Let me just bring the two ounces to our house and blew up and I brought,
at that time,
it was like an ounce and a half and three quarters.
This bitch pick me up at six in the morning with a case of Starbuck coffee in
Canada,
half a gown on the backend,
and we went back to their house and we did that whole package of blo heroin,
alliums,
BMA,
a GSP.
We did how many days,
how many days,
who days chases cry is got.
It was the fucking Houston's kept calling me and I'm like,
fuck you motherfuckers.
I'm out of commission.
Right.
That's all.
Finally that wix week was the grammys.
Last time ever I seen Whitney Houston.
I got a call on a Monday morning after the grammys at nine in the morning and
they're like,
is your boy up?
He'd have to be,
I'm getting me.
And they pull up to my fucking house where I lived by the YFCA and it was the
manager,
Whitney Houston and Ricky Martin in the fucking back.
And they're all gone.
They're gone from the Grammy's that jaw,
all of them,
jaws or fucking go and Jack and I got in the car with them.
I drive for the Martell cocktail.
I'm sitting there like,
oh,
I don't even know what drinking month.
I just looked out the window.
I was more paranoid than he was.
I got in,
bought it and brought it back to the college.
Right.
That's the last time I fucking say eating.
All this story's going to get on the Internet.
You know?
11 years ago it wasn't,
he wasn't going to say to me,
Oh,
you remember me bitch.
What the Fuck Joe Rogan,
why got to bothering me with this shit?
Well,
I was sitting there.
I would have the time,
like gentlemen,
you got to talk to me about chimps eating babies.
What the fuck kind of Bennett table conversation is this cocksucker okay,
but it hit the fan every now and then.
You'd be in Jersey going,
where the fuck are you?
I'm not going to lie to your dog.
I never left Vegas,
but
I still remember when I was playing kickball with Lucy Snowe Bush.
Real name Joey.
Not a real name.
Fucks up.
Carly's big bitch,
but she was like five,
eight grade.
I broke into Aslan and ate her pussy with,
I'll quit.
I just couldn't take it.
The bitch was banging my uncle.
My mother died.
Very small grounds as Bob Bender was Lucy small Bush
like old.
Oh Susanna be right for me.
The door.
I knew she was out drinking so she was going to say nothing.
I didn't jump on the bed.
Ain't [inaudible].
My
name is Lucy smoke and she was fuck how grill was.
Okay.
Bobby was bagging from the time she was like seven ish was buying it.
I was like,
Hey,
I met her,
but she doesn't have what?
She used to have a on the old one broke into her house.
I was like 17 it was walking down the house.
I'm thinking about who's who see am I on the,
and I was out like she was out earlier.
Whenever she drank,
she was kind of loose dog.
I went right into how you got,
oh,
ladder up,
climbed up the fucking ladder,
open the window.
She's like,
who's there?
Who's been the one either that is fucking pull the pants.
Eight a monkey climb back out of like a fucking vampire.
She seemed like a week later she was like,
that was amazing.
Yeah.
I don't know the movie he was dancing and singing and Nick's,
you know he's dying oxygen.
No,
not not right,
but junkies and jumping.
He's a junkie is a junkie.
Every day you guys are wake up singing dance and then he has oxygen tanks at
night.
Something's not right there.
In my case,
like most schools,
you're worth more dead than what you are alive yet.
I mean he's worth more now than he's ever been.
I think he killed Michael Jackson.
What's changed where they go on Fox News?
Don't give a fuck no more.
Cause nobody's said that.
Say don't give a fuck.
Why would day so these kids have coming back.
This is the worst.
It doesn't matter if they're addictions.
Cussing is what's bad.
You can't do nothing to me that Castro hasn't already done.
And when this shit goes down,
isn't that in Scarface?
Yes.
Right.
And I gotta record that mother fucker right there on the flight afterwards and I
had fucking them bag.
I know that for misconduct,
which if I had a little bag of reefer referring my fucking no,
you didn't do this.
A conspiracy thing.
This is just to show you how hard do you have?
What people are working with that fucking x ray machine.
I had it in the bag here and I put it under my left nut.
No.
Okay.
We're not telling the story.
That's yes.
What freedom was.
Breeze come all Obama right now,
mother.
They said,
we're going to put you to the extra machine.
I'm standing there sweating bullets with this baggy under my fucking
bigger than the right and look cause I'm a righty stop.
People don't know.
That's what I had cancer for a couple of weeks.
You know the opposite hand is only 50 minutes in the control room.
When my legs open,
you're like Rodney danger
that was picking up a storm.
Not to mention my balls.
I'm sweating now because I'm going to go to jail time
and he shook my hand.
I'm like,
my tax payers.
A harder word.
Hey,
go fuck yourself.
You've got,
hold on,
hold on one second.
Hey,
good job.
Take a shuttle.
Joey Diaz,
Facebook.
Check yourself before you wreck yourself.
Fixing gas.
I get out of here.
You're in trouble.
I'm powering fire.
I'm throwing.
All right.
Listen,
I'll stay black cause that's the most important.
Okay.
Hey Joe.
The second he leaves the room.
I'm totally talking about how awesome.
Yes.